okay this was the really big story over
the weekend and this gets to the heart
of
almost everything that is wrong with
society right now and that's why we had
to cover it
so kristen cinema is a democratic
senator from arizona i would say she's
one of the last sort of remotely
moderate democrats there aren't many yes
i know your uncle is one and there's a
couple that you're friends with every
now and again but in terms of
influential
moderate old-school liberal democrats i
would say bill maher for whatever my
frustrations are with lamar he's one
there's there's a few of these people
left cinema actually in many ways is a
progressive but all she's doing in this
case uh is saying that she will not vote
for this 3.5
trillion dollar spending bill okay and
joe manchin is doing the exact same
thing
she's saying it's just too much spending
and she also is tacitly acknowledging
that they're lying because they keep
telling you 3.5 trillion
will cost nothing now the way they're
rationalizing that
is that they're saying it won't add
anything to the deficit because we're
just going to take money from other
people it's a it's an extraordinary lie
anyone with basic math would understand
not even math i mean you just have to
take one logic class to understand that
if you spend 3.5 trillion dollars it's
not zero even if you just steal it from
other people that's still spending money
okay it's just not adding to your to
your own personal debt and i have no
doubt that it would add to the debt
anyway because we're a debtor nation and
we got to pay interest and china may
come collecting some of that stuff one
day so we're probably gonna have to bomb
them but that's a whole other story
anyway kristen cinema is taking what i
believe is a principal position saying
this bill is just way too much in
spending by the way joe manchin who i
said is the other democrat that is not
going for this thing he posted publicly
a letter that he had sent to chuck
schumer i think about two months ago
where he said basically chuck i'm not
going to sign on to anything more than
1.5 trillion now this thing's 3.5
trillion and i get it they just make up
the numbers it's all nonsensical um but
it's not as if manchin is suddenly doing
something that people didn't expect him
to do and cinema was thought of as not
sort of like the perfect crazy leftist
that was always going to go on the party
line anyway she uh was chased into a
bathroom i believe this is at the
arizona capitol am i right uh the
university sorry at the university of
arizona state she was chased into a
bathroom by several activists uh we'll
tell you more about the activists in
just a sec
okay i'll be back
we want to talk to you real quick can we
talk to you about i actually i am
heading out
but um right now is a real moment that
our people need in order for us to be
able to talk about what's really
happening we need a buildback better
plan right now
we we're not going forward we need
solutions to build that better plan need
has the solutions that we need we
knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us we
need seven million citizenship for seven
million we need the
benefit right now
my name is blanca i was brought here to
the united states when i was three years
old and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sc 1070 and i'm here
because i definitely believe that we
need this pathway to citizenship my
grandfather passed away two weeks ago
and i was not able to go to mexico and
visit him because there is no pathway to
citizenship and if we have the
opportunity to pass it right now then we
need to do it because there's millions
of undocumented people just like me who
share the same story or even worse
things that happened to them because of
sb 1070 and because of anti-immigrant
legislation and this is the opportunity
to pass it right now and we need you to
we need to hold you accountable to what
you told us what you promised us that
you were going to pass when we knocked
on doors for you it's not right
[Music]
i'm a survivor
and a survivor of human trafficking and
it's
okay so let's just be clear about
something here the girl who's doing most
of the talking there that they you know
once they followed cinema into the
bathroom she's an undocumented immigrant
that's what she says herself she's an
illegal immigrant so she is here
illegally she is basically stalking
a sitting member of the senate in the
bathroom demanding that she
does what she wants to do we helped you
get in and now you got to do what we
want you to do i mean
i don't want to make this about that
girl but it's like
why is she here now right like if you're
undocumented and we know you're
undocumented and i'm not i'm really not
like some crazy immigration hawk either
i i believe especially for young people
that were brought here if they're you
know functioning productive members of
society that aren't involved in crime
and everything else we should have that
pathway to citizenship and again it's
one of those things much like i often
talk about with abortion where if we
were in a sane society we could talk
about the marginal cases we could talk
about the common ground but basically
you have an undocumented immigrant
busting into a bathroom with a couple
other people
to in essence they're threatening her
like why else are you getting in her
face now we all know that maxine waters
said you should get in their faces she
was talking about conservatives in this
case i don't know if she fully thought
it would come to roost in her own party
with her own uh you know democratic
senators um but this is what they want
in in essence i'll have a quote from
blanca who was talking there she said i
was brought here to the united states
when i was three years old in 2010 both
my grandparents got deported because of
sb 1070. so her grandparents obviously
came here illegally they got deported we
could debate whether that was right or
not or what their individual situation
is but now she's undocumented but she
has the gall as an undocumented citizen
as someone that is here illegally
to chase a senator down into the
bathroom now we know we know that this
isn't going to get major play obviously
on cnn or on msnbc or on washington post
or new york times because this doesn't
fit the narrative right this is well in
a certain respect it does fit the
narrative in that it's oh this senator
is not extreme enough so the base is
angry but then it would have if they did
cover it truly and honestly they would
have to uncover the real issues here of
why are undocumented people harassing
senators uh but let's be very clear
about something which is that if these
were a bunch of trump supporters or
conservatives or
anti-abortion activists or anything else
remotely thought of as crazy right which
is everything except looney left
we know that they these people would be
arrested that we would be arresting
family members they would be breaking
into houses and looking for documents
and everything else but this is what
they have wrought now even more
fascinating than all of this is that joe
biden was asked about this incident this
morning asked about whether you know you
can just follow senators into the
bathroom and start yelling at them
here's what joe said mr president
mr president you're talking about how
you have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two
have been pressured over the weekend by
activists joe manchin had people on
kayaks show up to his boat tl adam
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them
so it's it's it's part of the process
yes
it's part of the process that's the part
where he said the honest thing it's part
of the process meaning yeah if you
harass people that don't agree with me
it's part of the process yeah yeah we've
got secret service so you usually can't
get to us but you know it's part of the
process just imagine if donald trump had
said that imagine if anti-abortion
activists busted into a bathroom started
harassing aoc and then trump was asked
about it he said that's part of the
process
we would be in an impeachment now right
this moment same day impeachment three
the trilogy it would be here
these people are just liars they lie
about absolutely everything and they
will gladly use intimidation and
political violence when they can